[Music]
the highwayman has just dropped on
Netflix and was this real-life crime
thriller is currently picking up a lot
of mixed reviews I thought I'd bring you
my thoughts to let you know whether it's
worth staying in for this weekend
the film centers around the two
policemen that were tasked with hunting
down real-life infamous fugitives Bonnie
and Clyde the highwayman played by Kevin
Costner and Woody Harrelson not only
struggle with taking down the criminals
but also their personal conflicts it's
clear that both are living in a world
that disregards the law as a nuisance
and hates them for merely trying to
protect the population just opposing
this Bonnie and Clyde are viewed by
society as heroes even though they
attacked the innocent mercilessly and
had to be stopped this adds a lot of
depth to the film and the evolution of
the Highwaymen into becoming just as bad
as the people they are hunting down
definitely elevates air from a plot
perspective this complements the movie
and has to be said that the music
cinematography and setting had a lot to
the film grounded in a comb that many
will find fascinating this is a dark cop
thriller and those who find enjoyment in
the straight-laced great films will
probably like this more than most this
is pure Kevin Costner and Woody
Harrelson doing well Kevin Costner and
Woody Harrelson the latter always seems
ready to throw down for a fight whereas
the former grunts and mumbles his way
through the movie for the majority of it
now whether you like this or not it's
going to be a big factor and whether you
are able to enjoy the movie personally I
love the two actors and this film
cements them as a class act that really
showcases they are the best from their
generation they used long stairs
silences and body language to get their
point across and slowly work their way
up through the trail of the outlaws
until they eventually come head to head
with
however for summit this may be dull and
if there's one continued criticism that
I've seen towards the film it's that
it's meandering with little payoff the
work seems to sell a lot of things that
doesn't eventually deliver upon
impactfully and overall this makes it
quite difficult to sustain your
concentration for and the film isn't too
focused on the main part one of the
biggest failings of the film I think is
that it doesn't really bring any focus
to bonnie-and-clyde beyond their legend
this could have really been an
interesting psychology study of the
thought process of a murderer and how
those tasked with hunting them down must
match their mind state overall this is a
good addition to the platform and I did
enjoy the film I recommend that you give
it a watch at some point this weekend
though but I wouldn't cancel your plans
for it the Highwaymen gets a solid seven
out of ten and now on to the real-life
story the Highwaymen acts as a more
condensed version of the true tale of
the two as they track down the infamous
duo and because of this many events
happen a lot faster than they did in
real life Bonnie Parker and Clyde Barrow
originally met in 1930 but they didn't
begin their crime spree until two years
later it's raged across the United
States until 1934 on Frank Hamer played
by Costner in the film ambushed the
couple and killed them with the help of
police Hamer pumped over a hundred and
thirty rounds into the pair until they
were eventually brought down whilst
Bonnie and Clyde had been memorialized
in film throughout the decades the
Highwaymen is the first movie to Imbert
his perspective after a string of
escapes and robberies
Texas Governor Miriam Ferguson played by
Kathy Bates convinced Hamer to come out
retirement and instructed him to kill
the gang Hamer was an old school lawman
that had spent decades fighting
bootleggers the KKK and smugglers unable
to pay Hamer he was instead instructed
to take whatever he wanted from the
group's possessions Hamer was able to
follow the gang but didn't get an
opportunity to take them down until 1934
after the family of Henry Madden agreed
to set up an ambush point in exchange
for a pardon from the state of Texas
Hamer and the Dallas County Sheriff's
managed to kill the two and whilst the
film even shot this scene on location at
where they died it's impossible to
guarantee whether this is accurate or
not this is purely due to the fact that
there's been so many conflicting
accounts but one thing that is confirmed
by all is that the police fired first
whether there was warning give
or not is up for debate but it's fair to
assume that the police were pretty on
edge after the several murders that
there had been by the pair it's safe to
say that their suspicions were
well-founded - as in the car Hamer
described them as carrying an arsenal on
wheels
this included several automatic rifles
sawed-off shotguns 10 pistols and over
5000 rounds of ammunition in the end
Hamer kept the weapons and also took a
box of fishing gear the rest of the gang
were eventually caught and executed with
melon beans sentence for murder in
Oklahoma before dying in 1955 overall
it's a fascinating tale and I highly
recommend that you look further into it
if the Netflix film has piqued your
interest if he enjoyed or disliked the
movie then make sure you leave your
review in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this video then make sure you
check out my trailer breakdown of scary
stories to tell in the dark which would
be linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]